Pixar has officially sold out at one
point the animation company seemed like
a beacon of artistic high-mindedness for
crying out loud
they had to be talked into doing a
sequel to Toy Story they understood that
sequels and prequels can debase a brand
unless they are James Bond movies or
Lord of the Rings movies or Star Wars
sequels but not Star Wars prequels but
nowadays Disney is releasing original IP
like tangled and record Ralph while
Pixar's endless sequels and brand
extensions would put the frito-lay
corporation to shame this is exactly how
my guys never played Disney look Toy
Story 3 was all well and good and Cars 2
was it was no worse than cars
but now there's monsters University
finding dory planes made by the same
Disney studio that brought you straight
to video classics like Mulan - what's
next
monsters middle school before a bug's
life wall-e on ice I don't say this
lightly but Pixar's on the verge of
becoming just another DreamWorks what's
your favorite fictional Pixar sequel
send me the poster I'll hang it in my
office I could use a little more
decoration around here have you not
subscribe to the wire channel yet don't
make me angry